-Our next guest is
an Emmy-winning actor you know
from his work in the critically
acclaimed series "The Americans"
as well as movies like
"A Beautiful Day
in the Neighborhood."
He stars in "Perry Mason,"
which returns
for its second season
March 6th on HBO and HBO Max.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend
Matthew Rhys, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Well, I am so happy
you're here again.
-I'm always pleased to be here.
Very happy to --
-You're here on a very special
day for a Welshman.
-It's -- Well, yes.
We're on the eve, on the cusp
of a very auspicious day.
Tomorrow, March the 1st,
is Saint David's Day,
the feast day of
the patron saint of Wales.
A Welsh Saint Paddy's Day...
-Okay.
-...as it's been told to me
a number of --
So it's basically
Welsh St. Paddy's day.
Yes, so, tonight is usually
a big night for us.
-Okay, gotcha. And is it a
little bit like St. Paddy's day
in there's some imbibing
of maybe some adult beverages?
-That's -- That's basically
all there is to do.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-That's all there is.
We wear red.
That's why the red socks are on.
-Okay, wonderful.
-Yes.
So there's a number of different
celebrations throughout --
throughout Wales.
-Are there any --
Are there any elements of it
that are sort of outside,
say, you know, binge drinking?
-The norm? Yes. Yes.
I mean, it became a tradition
with the Welsh regiment
of the British Armed Forces
on March the 1st to have --
The leek is the national symbol
of Wales.
-The vegetable, the leek.
-I'm sorry. Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Not when one relieves
themselves, yeah.
So the vegetable
is an odd choice, yes,
but there is history behind it,
which we won't go into.
So, the Welsh regiments
of the British Armed Forces
tend to have a leek-eating
competition on March the 1st.
-Okay.
-Which sometimes,
when we do imbibe too much --
and we think
this is a great idea --
I partake in
that celebration myself.
-So, now, we actually brought
a couple leeks, and now --
-Oh.
-These are --
Now, I'm very upset that there's
no preparation at all.
This is just a raw leek.
-This is a raw --
This is a raw leek.
-Okay.
-I mean, this is what --
-So, you asked for a stopwatch.
-I did ask for a stopwatch, yes.
It's all been planned.
[ Laughter ]
Also, the planning
has gone hideously wrong
because you have
very cleverly managed
to put the small one
closest to yourself.
-Oh, I -- Look.
-It's like that moment in
"Princess Bride" when he's like,
"You only think that happens..."
Yes.
-I'm happy to eat whatever.
Now, I'm gonna start by saying
I'm not even a fan of leeks,
but how -- When you say
a leek-eating contest,
like, how much leek
usually gets eaten?
-So, this being a standard,
average leek...
would take about an hour,
hour and a half.
No. It usually
does take a long time.
-Yeah. Well, nobody --
I think nobody ever,
when the leek is served, thinks,
"I'm gonna eat this
as fast as I can."
-No, not in one sitting and raw.
-Yeah.
-So I thought rather
than kind of cut together
some montage where you see us
throwing up and things,
we should probably
just do 30 seconds.
-And see who eats the most leek.
-See who gets the most
out of the leek.
-Okay. Gotcha. Alright.
-So, hang on.
I got a tutorial on this,
although it's overwhelming me
already.
-Now, these --
-These were brought in
from Wales.
They're grown by my father
in his back garden, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you so much.
Nobody ever brings leeks
with back stories.
-Seeing as it was
March the 1st --
Now, to my mind, this is also
the first televised leek-eating,
you know, USA vs. Wales
leek-eating competition.
-Yeah.
-So I say we play --
We play for the pin.
-Okay. Look at that.
It's got Wales
and the United States.
Here. Wait.
I'm gonna show them. Two flags.
This is a very exciting pin
to play for.
-Yeah, this is a pin
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There's a real likelihood that
this is the start of something
and this will take off
as a televised competition.
[ Light laughter ]
-This is my hope.
-Yeah.
-This is why I bought --
I bought shares
in a leek-growing business.
[ Laughter ]
In Pennsylvania.
-And this is one of those things
because I've invested
in a lot of your things.
-Yes, you have.
-And none of them
have gone well.
-No, but I continue to thank you
for your support.
Right. Hang on. Wait a second.
-Wait.
I want to also note that you've
asked for a bowl of mints.
-I actually --
In fairness to me,
I didn't ask
for a bowl of mints.
I asked for two shots
of Welsh whiskey.
-Oh, well, we have that, too.
There you go.
-Oh, look at that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-This is just --
This is turning out
to be the best Saint David's Day
I've ever had.
-Now, I should note --
I feel very fortunate right now
because my wife likes you
a great deal,
is a fan of your work,
has met you personally.
And that's gonna be so helpful
when I come home
with, like, leek breath.
-You can tell her it's a --
-Leek and whiskey.
-It's a Welsh tradition.
Like, "Darling,
it was a Welsh tradition!"
-It does sound very made-up.
-Yes.
-I'm like,
"You know St. Patrick's Day.
Well, everybody has one."
-Yeah, yes!
-Okay.
-All those dirty Celts.
-There's a lot of preamble
to the leek-eating.
-I've been trying to put it off
hoping the stage manager
will go,
"We've run out of time."
[ Laughter ]
He's like, "No, we haven't."
-It's a very strong,
a very pungent leek.
-It's the whiskey
you're smelling now.
-No. It's the leek.
-Let's just compare leeks
quickly like we always do.
Like we did
on our last birthdays.
-There you go. Look at that.
That's why -- That's why
you and I get along so well.
We have similar-shaped leeks.
-We've compared them
over the years.
-No jealousy.
-No, no.
-Just two guys
with very similar leeks.
-Admiration and congratulations.
-Oh, I'm waving mine
the wrong way.
Is it important when you --
-Oh, yes.
You should always hold it
from the green.
Always hold it from the green.
And the quick tip is,
as you're doing it,
you should try
and hum traditional
Welsh folk songs or Welsh hymns.
-Okay.
-Or if you don't know any,
anything by Tom Jones
will suffice.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-But humming it
will help it go down.
-Just hum. Help it go down.
-Yes.
-Okay, so, maybe a "three, two,
one" from the audience.
[ Clears throat ]
Whenever you're ready, audience.
[ Laughter ]
-Three, two, one! Go!
[ Both humming ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Audience chanting "Go!" ]
[ Both humming ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You can return the pin
to your lapel, sir.
[ Laughter ]
-Maybe we pose this
to the audience
because we didn't discuss.
[ Laughter ]
Remember in "Cool Hand Luke"
when he does the eggs?
-Uh-huh.
-And at the end, they're like,
"Ray, he's still
got egg in his mouth!"
-Yeah.
-So, having leek --
Where do we stand on having leek
in your mouth at the end?
-I don't know. This is --
You know, you're the expert.
I feel like you should decide.
-I've never done this sober.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, I think -- Here's whiskey.
[ Applause ]
-It's a very different
experience sober.
-Yeah.
It's a very hard vegetable
to work your way through.
-It is.
-Yeah, I think
you got me there, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, thank you.
-I brought two.
-You brought two?
Oh, very good.
-If there's one thing
the Welsh do, it's diplomacy.
So bring two pins.
-Alright.
Always -- That's the thing.
Always bring a second pin.
-Yes. Yeah.
-Now, wait.
I want to talk about your boat.
-Oh, God.
-You've got a boat
called Rarebit.
-Another Welsh-themed question.
Yes, I do.
-Now, here's the thing
about "Rarebit."
This was the name of this boat
before you bought it.
-In 1939, this boat was built
in Brooklyn and named "Rarebit."
So when I saw it on eBay
one drunken night,
I went, "Well, this is fate.
I live in Brooklyn."
-So you just got a mouthful
of leek and you're on eBay.
-Had a Welsh whiskey.
Keri was asleep.
I was like, "Buy."
I had all these giddy, dizzy,
rose-tinted plans
for this thing.
-Now, you do have this boat,
and you take people out.
You are the captain
of this vessel.
-Sadly, I'm not the captain.
I have a great captain,
Captain Kelly.
So, yes, we now charter it
because the restoration
took so long.
In the end,
myself and Captain Kelly,
we did the restoration.
We -- They call it
splining the hull.
We splined the hull.
We glassed it and everything.
So we now take six paying,
sane people out
in New York Harbor on a charter.
-And, now, what percentage
of them know you
as Matthew Rhys the actor
and what percentage just think
you're a weird guy with a boat?
[ Laughter ]
-I think 99% of people
think I'm the weird guy
with the boat when I'm like,
"Argh! Welcome to the boat!"
And they're like, what?
It's like, "Stop trying
to be Quint in 'Jaws.'"
And I'm like, "Alright."
But, yeah, sometimes
if the deckhand can't do it,
I go in and I kind of pretend
that I know what I'm doing.
-Alright, I have more questions
about your boat
and "Perry Mason."
We'll be right back with more
from Matthew Rhys.